para esta rm en la formula molecular es
100 9 h 10 continuamos calculando el
índice de deficiencia de hidrógeno
si tenemos 9 carbonos el número más
grande de hidrógenos que podemos tener
es de 2 por 9 + 2
y 2 por 92 es igual a 20 así que para 9
carbonos 20 hidrógenos es el máximo
número aquí solo tenemos 10 hidrógenos
nos hacen falta 10 hidrógenos y nos
hacen falta cinco pares de hidrógenos
por lo tanto el índice de deficiencia de
hidrógeno es igual a 5
con un y dh de cuatro o más alto piensas
en anillos de benceno así que continuaré
dibujando un anillo de benceno aquí
porque estoy bastante segura que hay uno
en nuestra molécula y si vemos aquí esta
señal que se ve bastante complicada son
realmente demasiadas señales
trasladándose de protones de un anillo
de benceno hice eso porque estamos en la
región de protones aromáticos para
nuestro r
mn
justo aquí tengo 5 protones aromáticos
déjame continuar
dibujando los
y mis cinco protones aromáticos solo
ambientes ligeramente distintos dándonos
señales traslapadas dándonos esta que se
ve bastante complicada aquí bien eso
corresponde a un y dh de cuatro pero
tenemos un y dh de cinco por lo que
tenemos uno más y por supuesto será un
enlace doble hice eso debido a esta
señal aquí abajo entre 9 y 10 recuerda
una señal entre 9 y 10
esa es la región para un protón de
aldehído
tenemos un protón de aldehído por aquí
dibujo mi carbón y lo dibujo a mi
hidrógeno y luego esta es otra pieza del
rompecabezas aquí este aldehído está
conectado a algo bien continuamos con
estas otras dos señales aquí abajo esta
señal representa dos protones
escribiremos un ch2 aquí cuantos
protones vecinos tenemos para esos dos
protones del ch 2 bueno hay 123 picos
hay tres picos solo resta uno para saber
cuántos protones vecinos tienes tres
menos uno es igual a 2 éste es 'un ch2
con dos vecinos es exactamente lo mismo
para esta señal cierto esto representa
dos protones sería un c h 2 y nuevamente
tenemos tres picos
1 2 3 3 - 1
estos este es un ch 2 con dos vecinos y
entonces estos 12 h 2 deberán de estar
justo uno al lado del otro
déjame dibujar eso aquí
si tenemos un ch 2 al lado de otro c h 2
cada uno de esos protones de sh2 tiene
dos vecinos por ejemplo si pienso en
estos de aquí cuantos protones vecinos
bueno este es el carbono de junto y
tengo dos protones vecinos eso tiene
sentido cuando veo a la señal en el smn
sólo hay una manera de poner juntas
estas diferentes piezas del rompecabezas
tendríamos que poner un ch dos saliendo
de este lugar en tu anillo de benceno y
luego otro ch2 y luego finalmente
nuestro aldehído
continuaré dibujando aldehído de esta
manera y entonces esa deberá de ser la
estructura de nuestra molécula
un poco sobre este protón de aldehído
déjamelo resaltó este protón de aldehído
aquí solo vemos un simple t en el
espectro rm n pero si tiene dos vecinos
déjame continuar dibujando el protón
vecino es este carbono de aquí si
piensas en el protón de aldehído este es
el carbono vecino y entonces tenemos dos
protones vecinos y con dos vecinos
pensarías que obtenemos algo de
desdoblamiento para la señal de este
protón de aldehído aquí pero no vemos
ninguno en el rm y normalmente no ves
ningún desdoblamiento porque la
constante de acoplamiento es normalmente
muy pequeña por lo que esta señal
regularmente se ve como un singlete pero
algunas veces si le haces una ampliación
puedes ver algo de desdoblamiento para
el protón r mn
para este rm n tienes una señal para dos
protones eso debería ser un c h 2 y
cuántos protones vecinos bueno para esta
señal tenemos cuatro picos 1 2 3 4
4 - 1 es 33 protones vecinos para estos
dos protones de h2 que pasaría con el
desplazamiento químico para esta señal
el desplazamiento químico se acerca a
cuatro partes por millón y en ese rango
nos hacen pensar en esos protones unidos
a un carbono que está unido a un átomo
electro negativo y si ves nuestra
fórmula molecular el único átomo electro
negativo que vemos aquí es oxígeno ese
oxígeno deberá de estar unido a este
carbono continuamos dibujando eso
y ese oxígeno está unido a este carbono
y ese carbono está unido a dos
hidrógenos eso es lo que tenemos hasta
ahora el oxígeno es más electro negativo
que el carbono el oxígeno quita algo de
densidad electrónica de estos dos
protones dándonos un valor más elevado
para el desplazamiento químico la señal
para estos dos protones en magenta está
justo aquí luego veamos esta señal
tenemos tres protones
ch3
cuántos protones vecinos bueno para
nuestra señal vemos uno dos tres picos
tres menos uno es dos dos protones
vecinos dos protones vecinos deberían
ser esos magenta así que déjame
continuar poniendo nuestro grupo metilo
aquí y usemos rojo para los protones del
metilo estos tres protones del metilo
nos dan esta señal
predijimos dos vecinos y esos protones
vecinos son los que están en magenta
aquí esos son los dos vecinos para los
magenta predijimos tres vecinos
1 1 2 3
finalmente veamos la última señal
tenemos sólo un protón más en qué pensar
sólo hay un lugar para ponerlo debería
de estar en el oxígeno
esto representa este es el espectro rm n
para un alcohol para el etanol así que
este protón en azul en esta señal en el
espectro de rm n
y el desplazamiento químico es difícil
de predecir para un protón de alcohol
usualmente es de 2 a 5 partes por millón
pero es muy difícil predecir exactamente
dónde va esta señal aquí arriba
y también pensamos en cuántos protones
vecinos tiene este protón azul el
carbono de junto tiene dos vecinos
pensarías esperar dos más un picos si n
es igual a dos dos más uno nos da tres
esperaríamos un triplete para esta señal
pero solo vemos un singlete y eso es
porque este protón este protón
alcohólico rápidamente pasó de una
molécula a otra y esta transferencia de
protón es tan rápida que el protón nunca
se queda en el lugar tiempo suficiente
para interactuar con ese protón vecino
entonces la máquina de rm n usualmente
no muestra ningún desdoblamiento y en
las condiciones correctas es posible
para que ocurra el desdoblamiento de
alcohol y podrías ver un triplete aquí
pero en la mayoría de los crm n sólo
verás un singlete la cual es otra pista
para tu espectro rml